foreign
[Music]
I know what you're thinking the parking
garage again
Nikki call it with the hottest defense
attorney in L.A art at work
in that stupid magazine ooh fantastic
yeah you know I don't care about that
stuff huh
in the last week how many interviews
have I driven you to I'm
press go to my
to my head Lisa
that's my place right there
no judgment
you've got a bit of a situation here
look at all that beautiful paperwork all
right now that we're all here can we uh
can we get started we're gonna need all
hands on deck if I keep pulling
all-nighters they're gonna have to carry
me down the aisle Nikki text me the
address hey Mickey I need help I have a
problem tell me something I don't know
I'm ashamed to admit I'm using you for
your brain again that's all I'm good for
I can show you what else you're good for
later if you want
[Music]
love all eyes being trained on you
Hello Mickey it's Lisa the arresting
room
[Music]
so now you're representing her let me
guess pro bono because you're frosting
her cake you're basting her turkey she's
battering your brisket okay I don't have
time for this
[Music]
huh
I can do this I'm gonna hide my powers
and be a normal man having a normal day
hang on
starting
don't
everyone thinks they know the Man of
Steel
but you've never seen the son of Jarrell
like this before who am I
what was that
man I'd like to interview you for the
Daily Planet uh sorry no comment Louis
these are the new interns I want you to
show them the ropes they can help me
with the story if we break this we'll
become real reporters
who is Superman Lois I know what
Superman is huh you think he's a plane
it kind of looks like a bird my
adventures with Superman two episodes
series premiere Thursday July 6 at
midnight on Adult Swim next day on max
I'm not sure how much longer I can keep
doing this
alive
the state road is dead the future of the
Republic rests on me
never been weak don't start now it's a
full scale famine I can't rule Rome if I
can't feed it the plan is the same we
make you a God we kill anyone who gets
in your way guys
what I'm doing yeah it could be fatal we
need to rebuild this behind that one
it will be dangerous
you need to show me already
that's the other way I'm not backing out
loud
I wish I didn't love you love
makes us weak
[Applause]
[Music]
knuckle decided to call has there been
another murder huh uh actually
[Applause]
get meat with that a neat rom-com sequel
this is not a sequel
number one suspect is the bride Zoe
system
Grace didn't do it we got a dead body
and a whole lot of people to talk to
what's your name you fine as hell Travis
we'd like to hear your accounts of what
happened I like to call them your mind
movies
it was all trouble and for the record
the case wasn't the only thing that was
hard oh God
everyone here had a motive
I have
many tales to tell actually maybe they
just start from the beginning of the
wedding I'm a Searcher okay
Edgar's crumb and Grace knows that I'm
was that pretty handy with a broom that
was a broom that's how I could tell
you've never swept before it's like a
lightsaber
oh it's actually my adoption day I don't
know when I was born
[Music]
this looks delicious that's potpourri
bon appetit
we know you're eating air freshener
[Music]
anyone could have done it
my mother says hello
[Music]
she went to be here but she was busy
with silence and alcohol
let us raise the toast to the happy
couple this whole thing is so much more
complex than you guys realize
we all have hours
well I think it's pretty clear that's
got our guy what did you say you got or
not not what
well I know who killed Edgar
to the tune the bridge with white people
whisper is never a good thing
Mavis the camera loves you well it must
be my Drumstick Emoji physique that's
what it is media on top nubby on the
bottom very delicious I love you so much
I love you
we spent the last five years building a
beautiful successful life together
that girl's having a moment it's moment
I think I was having a moment I did the
work it didn't work it's time to put
babies first I'm in for you this is me
trying to be single at 38 and to start
over being a roommate it's a special
kind of friend I think we should breathe
together
did you have Shake Shack today
I'm trying to grow my brand I want to
take fashion and trust women to help
them love their bodies I want you to be
my stylist how does my cleavage sitting
pretty like two coconuts look at you
celebrity stylist
you're the boss now and if you don't
believe in yourself nobody else will
what in the brown City Tattoo
I will drink to that
Mavis Mavis I can help you get this
career off the ground right there okay I
have everything I need to make my own
way
I realize I don't do random and Casual I
do real and honest
your mom is here and she wants to take
you to church
Vegas Ukraine new life right now
let me know where you're gonna end up
[Applause]
are you okay
sorry
my ovaries were just high-fiving
[Music]
make me a vampire sure man
I thought the transformation would be
overnight but it's been 16 days I can't
turn into a bat yet
human form
I am running for a comptroller can't
wait to flex my blue color bonafides on
the debate stage three weeks ago
microphone microphone
this is the mall bikini warehouse must
be a front for a brothel I would like
you to honor these coupons that's just a
cut out photo of Ryan Seacrest
come on Gizmo let her rip
that's how we all learn
oh what how do you feel about taking the
virginity of a dead ghost
it's your lucky night
[Music]
this is the age of Darkness
foreign
I have dreams sometimes about things
that will happen
and I wake up terrified
[Music]
despair
death destruction
this is even bigger than the last crisis
[Music]
breathes respect
it requires it for its life the
foundation is a threat to me
I will look at them in the eye and
reclaim what is ours
for all of us to survive we have to face
them we need to be in the fire
[Music]
we fight for peace
not because we fear we will lose
but because we know
[Music]
that if there is war
[Applause]
we are taking the planet
it's time you and I had a reckoning
[Music]
now just listen to me I'm Deputy U.S
Marshal Rayland Givens and I'm offering
salvation talk to me come on face to
face I am not opening this door
then as they say in the Bible you're
screwed remember
Marshall welcome to Detroit
protective Lee gray Lynn Givens what's
up Slim
this ought to be good
I've got a task force with Detroit PD
you've been special requested I promised
my kid we got a whole road trip planned
back to Miami it wasn't a question
this guy left a trail of [__] from
Oklahoma to Detroit
he ain't got cash we got ourselves a
problem
Manziel shows up bad [__] is in the air
any information on this dude could help
us Clement Manziel is my client he's a
killer and he enjoys it
[Music]
hey
there he is
how are you supposed to be in that hat
Travis Tritt you know he did a great job
she's very sweet sweetheart why don't
you get upstairs
I see you near my daughter again
first
[Music]
I ain't gonna sleep at night the son of
a [__] wins
I don't know what you think you're doing
you want to play Let's Play
you won a shooting match
let's go
counted us out but we are back and we
are better than ever
how do you make it look so easy well the
real question is why do men make it look
so hard an iconic editor needs an iconic
publisher
we're 50 50 partners and I'm telling you
it's going to be different
actually 51.49
feels great to be back follow me to the
pool we have snacks and poppers in the
lounge
who are those people and why do they
keep taking their picture that's rolling
stone you really need to read my memos
Bambi oh I don't read memos on principle
but fun
in just six months sales are through the
roof we're going to be so much more than
just magazines
[Music]
does any man know where the clitoris is
on a female body absolutely not
we're taking this thing global
wow should have listed that as a special
skill
you said you wanted to be wow don't
worry wow
stick this in there I mean it's
stagecraft
[Applause]
and patriotic yum
[Music]
is there anything else are we no I think
that's it should we have sex now
so you sell magazines about vaginas huh
about vaginas no we're mostly in the uh
in the penis business now actually
are you close closer than we've ever
been contract agent or lioness lionesser
we locate the wives and Daughters of
these high value targets coming I mean
place an operative close to them and we
kill the target
we play this right it is over before
it's begun there's really no means to
abort you'll get her killed and expose
the entire program our asset is embedded
we don't have the ability to call her
off
shooting
so we're just going to pretend that a
CIA quick reaction force did not execute
a kill mission in front of CBS News
walk us through your decision to call
the Drone strike he was dead either way
you need to remember what you're
fighting for
your new home
our new home oh we're back baby
in two seconds you will collide with
your destination now good news everyone
we seem to have survived a massive
disruption in the flow of time wait what
exactly happened here look at this
stop hiding
okay I'm done pull the ship
a new virus has broken out I've
developed a test to see who's infected
you Sham this Q-Tip up your nose
that looks kind of fun I can't wait to
do it hundreds of times
pretty Lawless out here in crypto
country
you interested in a job
[Music]
why don't you have a belt or at least a
substantial butt sorry guys I'm a flatty
[Music]
men's gave me gifts that's in order
out
I deserve that
I'm just glad you're back
would you like to order erotic scented
massage oil or fuzzy handcuffs yes guys
that's creepy yeah I mean yeah so creepy
[Music]
neutrality
red one get you a statue
shut up
but it'll certainly happen keeping you
alive
[Music]
I won't abandon Siri
you try to see has consequences too
you're right I'm right well that's
deeply worrying
everything that's happening
it's all connected
when she's at the center of it
[Music]
if war is coming there is no hiding her
from it
you sure about this
are you
[Music]
history has a way of repeating itself
the dangers we've seen foretell an even
more menacing future
for the first time I understand real
fear
oh
my God the witches is that sir
I'll never get over how cute they look
for Monsters and they're like mirror
please don't hurt me and then wow
just like a boatload of fangs all up in
your business
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen start your engines
laughs
[Music]
I'm back
I can see that
hell just got a room something's off a
worm
the Archangel Gabriel has disappeared
I think he's gone to Earth
hello hello good morning officer exactly
I'm a human police officer
you spotted Gabriel he's definitely not
in the shop it's just a zero fail the
traitor
and his grumpy friend Mr Crowley
the demon oh I suppose that explains the
grumpiness really there's something
urgent that I need to talk to you about
oh and of course his assistant either ah
Gabriel what's he doing here I don't
know what's happened to it I don't know
why did you come to my shop you know
what it's like when you don't know
anything at all and yet you're totally
certain that everything would be better
if you were just near one particular
person no so I'm certainly not
he's in trouble
everybody haven't held we do it together
together
what we figure out what's actually going
on
I think I may have just started a war oh
hello
[Music]
you did I'm going to get into so much
trouble well then let's make it
worthwhile
[Music]
who am I
[Applause]
a man his wife and son have left hand
and don't know where his brother is
[Applause]
I don't know what I have to do to find
the guy that I was before
[Music]
I'll figure it out
twos supposed to be the two of us
working together I need my own plan that
puts wrestling behind me
[Music]
to want to walk through this life
together but I
we gotta figure out how to make you
whole again
we should make this into what it can be
if we work together
crystals really something you and me
need to stop letting other people make
our decisions for us I should be able to
defend my title in the ring
Bristol meet El Dorado
baddest the dwl has ever seen I love
that shirt
it's uh every man for a self-type of
world watch me take everything you got
Jack Spade can't take you to the top but
I can when are you gonna get back to
wrestling we gotta pack the house
everything in life is a choice
you're an alarm
[Applause]
it's times like this as I wish this is
all fake
Preston can give a person something
worth striving for strength to be your
best be when sometimes you're at your
weakest
[Music]
who is this mystery guess
would you still remember me
[Music]
wherever you go in this life
they're Bound to You
away from you
my friend told me to keep clear of you
the victim was Navajo
[Music]
you got any leads you got a blonde man
here coming down to the resin killing
Indians
okay someone else is involved sooner a
lady will pop his head out what
this belonged to my son he wore it on
the day he died
wait for him they kill someone I'm gonna
need something here this is personal
evil grows the monsters ain't just in
the shadows they're in Broad damn
daylight
[Music]
I have to find out who's behind this
by any means necessary
get out
everyone has to die eventually